MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20 Special Relativity.
In this short section,
we want to introduce
a new notation, four-vectors.
And if you look at
previous discussions,
this is actually not that new.
We have seen that we need
to treat time and space
in a consistent manner.
And you have often applied
Lorentz's transformation,
for example, to a vector of
time and the next component
of space.
Now you just want to do
this with x, y, and z here
and not treat the y component
and z component as 0.
So as a starting point, you
can just simply say, OK,
we have this new four-vector.
And the 0's component
is the time or time
times the speed of light.
And then the first component,
second and third component
are the spatial
component, x, y, and z.
Now I wrote a
vector Xi mew here,
with the mew being
the upper index.
I can also introduce
Xi with a lower index.
And you see little y
and little y is useful.
Where the 0's component
is not t but minus ct--
but minus ct.
As a reminder for
three-vectors, you
learned about the dot
product, which is just
a multiplication of
two, three-vectors
where all vectors with n
components, where you multiply
the same component
of each vector
and add those results together.
So the dot product of
vector a and vector b
is the sum of all
indices for ai and bi.
Now for our four-vector,
we do the very same thing.
We just sum over
all four components.
And we treat the
vectors as a product
of the vector with the lower
index and the upper index.
And you find here then
we get minus c squared t
squared plus x squared,
y squared, and z squared.
More generally, this is for
two vectors of the same-- two
of the same vectors.
More generally for
two different vectors,
you can write in this way.
Or in short, you can
define a new notation
in which you basically sum over
all indices which are equal.
So here we have an upper
and lower indices together.
So you sum over
this case here where
there's the same index,
mew, for both vectors.
And one is lower
and one is upper.
And we can continue
the introduction
and just introduce a few tools
to work with those vectors.
For example, if you wanted
to bring the component
mew from the bottom
to the top, you
can do this with multiplying
the vector with a matrix.
And the matrix here is
also called a metric.
And simply what
you have to do is
multiply the first
component with the minus 1
and the rest with 1.
You see this here
on the diagonal
and on other
components later on.
What this does-- you can
check this if you want--
is bringing the
index of the vector
from a lower to an upper one.
An interesting
example is the product
of a four-vector with itself.
And we have already seen
this because we saw this
as our invariant interval.
Here, the four-vector is the
distance in space and time
between two events.
So we looked at delta Xi
mew times delta Xi mew.
And delta Xi mew is the
difference between event A
and B. And so we have
seen this already
and calculated the
invariant and showed
that this squared over
a distance of two events
is actually invariant in
the Lorentz transformation.
But there's other
examples for vectors.
The first one we'll investigate
some more in the next sections
to come.
It's the energy
momentum four-vector,
where we place in the first
component the energy--
in the 0's component the energy,
and then the first, second,
and third components the
three-vector of the momentum.
But there's others, for
example, the four-potential,
where in the 0's
component, you have
the potential-- the
electric potential.
And then the first, second,
and third component,
you have this new
field A, which is
related to the magnetic
and electric field.
So E and M is not
part of this course,
but we'll come back to
this in the last week
and discuss the consequences
and ideas a little bit more.
But if you then look at the
invariant four-vector, which
is a product of the
energy momentum vector,
you find that the first
component, the energy square
or minus the energy
square over c
square plus the three-component
vector of the momentum squared.
And that's constant, we can just
here name this mass or minus
mass square times c square.
So if you write this, you
find this energy momentum mass
relation E squared is equal
to p squared c squared, plus m
squared c to the fourth power.
And if you look at
this four particles
of 0 momentum, in which case
this component here is 0,
you find the equation E
is equal to mc square.